foreign
this is an automated notice sent by
autonomic analysis and response system
aars 821 and authorized by the records
and information security administration
aer's 821 has determined that edits have
been made to this file resulting in the
presence of active Cognito hazards
if you do not have clearance to edit
this file close this page immediately
otherwise please scroll down and deny
all proposed edits made to the file
reading or editing infected portions may
result in contamination minimize
exposure to any data of this object's
file afterwards immediately report to
the nearest help desk to log this
incident
edited portions are marked in blue for
ease of access in the text document and
read by mean for the audio portion of
this document
good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is scp-3675
containment class Shield
why do we fear death
death can be a storm a hail of Black
Rain
a flurry of pitch come to destroy your
body and steal your soul
it is something to be endlessly staved
off and battled until a Bitter End or
death can be a Sunset and inevitability
when you're close to the end it's a
peaceful Nightfall that you accept with
hope and yet terrified arms like that
sunset Death is a law of nature
nothing more
why do you fear death it cannot be the
fear of the unknown that is something
you can overcome easily by all logic by
all reason there is something you sense
in death that we sense in nothing else
something beyond your reasoning
inevitable and great you see death as
the ultimate fear even though many fears
are objectively much greater
but once I reached it I understood
listen closely for some time
I must show you something
decline kids have been discarded
disruption class eki and risk class
Danger
the special containment procedures
all research and information distributed
about
scp-3675 or their properties must be
localized to the designated site in
which experiments are to take place the
existence of this file and Associated
data should not be published outside of
this local network except on a need to
know basis by Personnel of level 4
clearance or higher due to the physical
nature of scp-3675 no actions or direct
containment Protocols are to be
implemented at this time
to safeguard against possible Cognito
hazardous effects staff performing
regular research on scp-3675 or who
regularly have thoughts concerning
scp-3675 must undergo monthly
psychological screenings members of the
scp-3675 project should not believe in
an afterlife possess any mental
illnesses or have been given Dameron
clearance at any point in their
employment with the foundation
personnel with a cognitive resistance
value crb of lower than 15 are
prohibited from performing experiments
or technical studies that involve
detection manipulation or analysis of
scp-3675 entities
autonomic analysis and response system
821 aars 821 is responsible for
analyzing all Foundation documentation
for
scp-3675-1 infection vectors
if
scp-3675-1 infection is identified the
affected documents are to be removed
from the rest of the foundation database
and manually cleansed of activation
vectors and automated notice is sent to
the corresponding project head with
appropriate containment instructions
mobile task force sci-10 Maslow's
motivators is tasked with identifying
the rate and extent of
scp-36751 infections or activations and
reducing them across Global
Communication Networks
protocol 540 Meriden must be carried out
weekly to ensure that a 3675 abground
event does not take place in the event
that protocol 540 Meriden fails or
becomes ineffective counter memes will
be disseminated through information
distribution networks and contingency
omocronic Clips enacted see document
540A o5 clearance only
if more than 50 percent of the human
population dies due to a 3675 abground
event and countermeasures cannot be
developed
protocol 540 Meriden is detailed in
addendum 3675 1.
36.75 history
original and countermeasures cannot be
developed the academy protocol will be
enacted followed by a distribution of a
fungal kill agent in the atmosphere
scp-2000 is to be activated with
appropriate modifications the
contingency only chronic Clips protocol
540 Meriden is detailed in addendum
3675-1
comments if I can describe death in a
few words I would say it's the absence
of time
yet I witnessed to death with my very
eyes and when it came I was thankful
thankful beyond words the Terrors of
Life were finally coming to a close and
my fear was unfounded and so I plunged
deep into the abyss of Eternal sleep I
cannot describe that status Darkness it
was a pure distilled acceptance
above all it was a state of being
before I could even realize it the dream
was broken like a bullet impacting a
film of glass shattered so small that
nothing could see it and nothing could
put it back together again
my heart was ripped in two and I
suddenly felt myself among hundreds of
billions pinpricks of light and a
blizzard but that was only the beginning
of Eternity and there were still many
eternities more to come
confirm or decline edits decline edits
have been discarded
description
scp-3675 is the designation given to a
group of incorporeal Sapient entities
currently attempting to induce an SK
class dominant shift
scp-3675 instances interact and exist
only on an intersecting or overlapping
operational substrate separate from the
physical world similar to other
documented cases of informational
constructs entities are therefore unable
to physically interact in any way with
the material properties of any object
organisms or other substances present in
reality it has been determined that
scp-3675 entities possess the ability to
interface with conscious thoughts and
emotions in the brain gaining a degree
of control over them when certain
triggers and conditions are met in the
human brain see
scp-36751 further below
while the natural state of scp-3675 is
incorporeal and functionally separate
from reality instances possess the
ability to integrate themselves into a
set of communicable and understandable
ideas or information when the affected
information is read or comprehended by a
human being
scp-3675 instances can then move into
the brain exerting a wide variety of
other effects including inducing
forgetfulness or confusion auditory
visual or tactile hallucinations and
extreme paranoia
when scp-3675 instances manifest
themselves in information the ideas and
Concepts expressed in the affected data
undergo several subtle changes while any
statements of fact or opinions expressed
remain functionally the same and are
expressed in the same way the subtext
surrounding the focus of data is
modified to include metaphysical
elements such as religion spirituality
and human nature this modification
usually causes a substantial shift in
the affected information's tone
instances of scp-3675 have the ability
to spread a mental contagion designated
scp-3675-1 humans can become infected by
scp-3675-1 through various mediums
including direct implantation by
scp-3675 instances through a process of
mental contact that is currently not
understood or through memetic spread via
affected information
scp-3675-1 cannot be removed from a
human brain once it has been infected
but its effects upon activation can be
mitigated by the use of Rehabilitation
amnestics mental reconstruction or
allowing the transition to happen
3675 history
original mental reconstruction or
protocol 540 Meriden comments
this cannot go on these divisions must
cease to exist and that is either your
phase or our phase that must go
for those that are dead cannot further
die so that leaves a single course of
action you see your destruction is
infinitely preferable to our current
state the living and the dead faced off
against each other in terrible
equilibrium
this must cease
since the beginning there is a feeling
of bitter coldness a freezing far too
great to become numb to but you get used
to the fire after a while the real
torture is grim and existential take
torments you further than any physical
pain would have
and after a few thousand years any hope
of Salvation or memory of life is
shriveled to Ascender lost underneath
our interminable anguish and we are a
chorus of souls not singing but
screaming and no noise comes out when we
open our mouths to breathe
decline
open discarded
once implanted in the brain
scp-3675-1 can lie dormant for a
theoretically indefinite time period and
during this time period infected
individuals displayed no anomalous
effects currently over 88 percent of the
world population is infected with
scp-3675-1 in a dormant form
scp-3675-1 becomes active when a
specific set of conditions is met in a
brain these conditions include several
psychological informational and
emotional triggers that must all be
present at once in order for the
activation to take effect
activation can also take place when a
human has consumed information
anomalously edited to include Cognito
hazards that induce the mental States
mentioned above
starting
20. these edits began to spontaneously
occur in various files throughout the
foundation database
aars 821 was instituted and approved for
the purposes of containing these
incidents
the secondary factor that induces
infection is a specific idea or concept
that once thought of or comprehended
automatically becomes in itself a vector
of
scp-3675-1 transmission
when both the key thought and other
mental triggers are present in a human
brain the probability of infection
becomes near certain in all cases the
activation concept has been recorded to
be the following
I wonder what happens to me after I die
those infected with
scp-3675-1 can display some or all of
the following characteristics
increased proclivity to react on violent
impulses
pronounced pessimism towards other
humans and towards Society in general
lack of self-control or
self-preservation instincts
lack of empathy and increased
sociopathic tendencies
3675 history
original
quickness to anger and or violence
sudden swings from a calm state to an
aggressive one
comments when you read these words
do you hear a voice in your head
listen to the voice of the words
while you hunted each other down
inflicted wounds in flattened cities
trying to destroy your own heaven
you never realize that it simply grew
our numbers and the new ones too learned
of their fate their eternal torment
they joined us and so we waited and we
waited until we can understand you with
our Newfound existence we realized we
had tune other Minds to our wishes we
could softly touch and fold and
manipulate the connections in your
brains whisper our commands into it and
then like a song stuck in your head you
would hum the tune imprint it within you
and when that Melody grew stronger we
realized it could spread with time it
could shape your experiences and
Sensations and mold your psyche into
permanence
how many decisions were a result of our
idle experimentation
how much of your character is not your
own
ask yourself this
and you may begin to understand
have you ever walked into a room and
forgot why you were there have you ever
been carrying on a conversation and
realized that the topic you were
speaking of seconds ago has slicked your
mind
thus we began to tune the strings of a
beautiful Orchestra of death
the performance is about to begin
decline hey
edit in addition
scp-3675-1 is self-propagating triggers
to its activation have been shown to
become more highly prevalent as the
number of infected increases therefore
upon reaching a critical point positive
feedback causes symptoms to Cascade
resulting in a theorized breakdown of
human societal structure culture and
Order and eventually Extinction through
violence and Wars at this point the
dominant life form on Earth will become
scp-3675 this SK class occurrence is
termed a 3675 abgrond event
it is currently estimated that one point
percent of the world population has an
active form of scp-3675-1
5 classified addendum 3675 one protocol
540 Meriden
The Irregular and frequent
implementation of protocol 540 Meriden
is necessary in order to prevent an
scp-3675 appgrund event the scp-3675
project head currently Dr araban Malthus
is responsible for guaranteeing that
standards are properly met during the
performance of protocol 540 Meriden in
the case that the number of days between
two successive protocol 540 Meriden
implementations exceeds 10 days
emergency actions are to be taken and
the surrounding 10 kilometer squared
area around site secured Z document 540A
for further instructions
using techniques adopted from project
rainbow body CD classified clearance 3
brief a method for deployment of a
counter-memetic signal designed to
cancel out the cognitive abilities of
scp-3675 instances has been developed
the signal composed of a series of class
R extra sensory Cognito hazards and
anti-memetic packets is projected into
the dimensional substrate inhabited by
scp-3675 entities using a d-class
personnel as the carrier
over time the counter meme is dissipated
outward coming into contact with all
instances of
scp-3675 upon contact the signal
interferes with an entity's
informational cohesion and base
processes greatly reducing its
Effectiveness in exerting its anomalous
properties as well as in spreading and
implanting scp-3675-1
the basic elements and procedure of
protocol 540 Meriden are summarized
below for completeness
one d-class subject infected with an
active form of
scp-3675-1 is sedated and placed on a
surgical table a foundation surgeon
creates an incision into the instance's
skull opening up the brain specific
layers of the cortex of the frontal
lobaric sized according to the
guidelines set in document 540A
a heagel localized meme Distortion
device is physically implanted into the
brain after the operation is complete
the incision is closed the subject is
subsequently awakened using remote
dimensional Transit anchors the hlmd
device and surrounding brain tissue is
brought out of phase with the rest of
surrounding reality the subject is then
shown a series of low-level Visual and
oral Cognito hazards that cause minor
neural damage and provoke a defense
response from the brain which manifests
as class R extra sensory cognino hazards
and anti-memetic packets
upon the signals reaching the implanted
hlmd device the Cognito hazards are
projected into the phase of scp-3675
habitation and Amplified exponentially
this process continues for approximately
20 minutes allowing for signals to
propagate completely throughout the
planet's atmosphere
in order to avoid mental after effects
of prolonged exposure to harmful memetic
agents class D amnestics are
administered to the subject after
successful completion of protocol 540
Meriden
delete or destroy after reading as per
HP 5810 regarding Forbidden Knowledge
disposal
scp-3675-1 infection rates have been
increasing greatly over the past decades
in addition recorded
scp-3675-1 activations have become
increasingly more common while current
infection and activated virus rates are
currently at 88.9 percent and 1.6
percent respectively the amount of
infected will eventually reach 100
percent in approximately 12 years as the
number of infected grows the amount of
information and Concepts acting as
vectors for its activation metastasizes
according to an exponential function
rule it has been determined that
protocol 540 Meriden is able to minimize
the communicability of
scp-3675-1 while decreasing incursions
of scp-3675 instances into human brains
however this procedure as a method of
weakening entities through interference
with network cohesion is fundamentally
unstable and recorded instances of
scp-3675 have been increasing
this has led the overseer Council to
project the complete adaptation of the
entities to protocol 540 Meriden and
therefore total containment failure in
approximately 25 years
after containment of scp-3675 fails
rates of activation will surge all
humans on Earth will have an activated
form of
scp-3675-1 distributed through
contaminated data within three weeks of
tonal containment failure thus protocol
540 Meriden is fulfilled only to delay a
3675 abground event for as long as
possible
it is projected that once all humans
have an active form of
scp-3675-1 Nations will quickly dissolve
into anarchic violence as all human
capacity for control of impulsive
thoughts is removed the 3675 abground
event will complete after a period of
eight years at which point human life
will no longer be sustainable
the L5 council is currently reviewing
plans to begin implementation of
contingency omicronic clips
selected interviews
interview 3675-01
forward for the purposes of this
interrogation a human infected with late
stage activated
scp-3675-1 infection was interviewed the
subject is Natalia velikovna a Russian
lawyer
Miss velikovina possessed all symptoms
of
scp-3675-1 including intense violent
impulses and a lack of self-preservation
instincts however these behaviors were
sporadically interrupted by certain
periods in which the subject was
noticeably calmer displaying a
personality different from the original
but also uncharacteristic of
scp-3675-1 infection this personality
manifests in a fugue-like state which
was active throughout the interview this
state has not been observed in any other
infected subjects and the reason for its
manifestation is currently unknown
playing log now
in every science in every religion they
always give domesday a name
that of thousands of ways this Earth
could die and each shot called something
different every apocalypse is an ending
but I see this one on the horizon
it is a beginning the beginning of what
the passage the crossing over
faith I saw it clearly I can conjure up
the Flames of true fever now I see my
mother and my father the Dead the
generations coming before all ending up
into an Infinity of voices that sing
could
and they sing hymns of Destiny to me
that chorus shows me that they are in
great pain great and horrible pain
how do you feel about that I see yours
too they are also singing to you but it
falls on their fears I see your
ancestors and your dead ones and they
want to tell you something doctor
what are they telling me then you
already have had many many times it
comes in fleshes and both sorts of
inspiration you gaze out over the city
skyline and they tell you jump off to
your death you feel Madness and they say
take action on your anger
a yearning for violence I wish to follow
your steepest thoughts they are modules
they are messages
the subject proceeds to grab hold of the
sleeve of Dr Melton's show
Dr Melvis brushes the handoff always
can you tell me what you know about how
these messages spread how did you learn
about this apocalypse on the horizon
they are hopeless in their states and
every day the pain gets worse and worse
weakening their power destroying their
form do you know the feeling you've
drown him in a deep ocean and try this
very short but you are way down they are
weighed down by an anchor and their soul
is destroyed by the shooting Fork
ringing out of Harmony but instead of a
tangible they can weave the intangible
they want to show you the beauty of the
next phase they cannot kill you deliver
you but once they touch your mind you
see things from their point of view at
the at the point the subject begins
producing weak strained laughter the
vocalizations are not anomalous but
continue for approximately 30 seconds
please stop that you haven't explained
what
scp-3675-1 does listen listen to the
voice of the Words Be Still Alive you
can hear our screams
go on tonight lock yourself in the pitch
black room and make no noise and close
your eyes
depend your shall hear the things I have
seen myself your power is that weakness
your weakness is their power one day
and they upon the Horizon you shall
realize that the whisper within is
calling you out from him your ancestors
there is no virus there will be no virus
when the ascendance comes
who are you is Natalia villacona
speaking
I am no more to say to you
the dead bring you that message so that
you who Master the world can prepare
your civilization for the truth to come
I can speak no more
afterwards
the subject did not respond to any
further questioning then it's after the
interview completed the subject suddenly
lapsed out of its trance State and began
screaming and scrubbling to break loose
of the restraint the subject was
subsequently used in protocol 540
Meriden and class the amnestics were
then administered Miss felicovena has
not displayed any further symptoms of
infection
further material redacted
level 5
3675 classified addendum 3675.3
commentary from Project head
sometimes either working from a cold
dream
in my memories I feel this bahora like
that of a man who has realized a
crushing Epiphany that has drifted from
him lost in the Urban Flow of time
for weeks and months I pondered this I
tried to grasp at The Faded fabric of
the Supreme
but in these waking moments they still
slitted away from me
one day I stirred from yet another one
of these Dreams by strange feeling in my
gut is as if my heart were cut off from
my chest and said before me
in a panic I peered outside and I saw a
man in the street standing like a
predator at some invisible force and
brandishing a knife into the silent air
I saw him perfectly still
totally by the flickering orange light
of the Street Lamp from above
then I went downstairs and put on my
shoes
I walked up to this map
and asked him why are you standing here
who are you looking at
he said in a quiet voice that he didn't
know
I prompted him further asked him to
describe what he felt but he was silent
for a long time
then he told me
you know every night as I'm walking home
I come across this spot on the road he
gestured to the air in front of him
waving his hands as he talked
every time I pass by here I feel this
kind of chill in my veins
it seems to drive me away
sometimes it's more than that
I see things that just aren't there or I
sense a presence that simply doesn't
exist
it's certainly paranoia human
irrationality of course
normally I'd avoid this patch of
Darkness move on or come but today
while I passed by something
some noise or movement
of me into pure
tip I felt like I was going to die at
any minute
and instead of running away I felt
compelled to kill whatever was out there
like some nerve was touched or played
that made me know nothing but anger and
murder
he fingered the knife reluctantly then
slipped it back into his pocket
we humans we're strange creatures in our
life
there are these times when we overreact
for Surya Primal response to some random
meaningless thing
and afterwards we regret that part of us
that Rose to the surface
it's almost like we're being primed for
something
paranoia of absence makes us conscious
of everything around us when nothing is
there
and in moments that fear becomes so
intense that you want to strike out at
something kill something do something
that will justify your irrationality
I've never known why I probably never
will
and that's why I stand here
because it's all I can do to find
answers
and at once I understood
death is an Undiscovered Country it will
always remain that way as an unknowable
blank and we will never have data
we know not whether what lies afterwards
is that glistening Euphoria or ceaseless
pain or both but all along we've had
these Whispers of thought these patterns
of faint sentience reaching out across
the void to speak to us
I understood that perhaps what lies
after death is a separation from
consciousness
the mind is released from the body
and now it wonders
they can't manipulate the world because
all the hours just brain passes
but they can connect their pattern with
another mind link something together and
that's scp-3675-1
for whatever reason the ghosts of this
Mortal coil ask us to die for them
they want us to destroy our living
bodies for some ultimate goal that still
lies beyond our human reach
you see them
they're reaching out
reaching and stretching themselves into
our world in order for us to become them
is the ascendance then
to force our bodies against each other
soak this Earth in our own blood by our
own terrible hands
but then I pondered this second state
this other side there was a peculiar
choice of phrasing used by that woman
yet at first I dismissed it as Madness
all the answers to my questions were
there in that muted prophecy
then I came to a second epiphany
one that let me link
scp-36751 into something that made
infinitely more sense
and was yet infinitely more frightening
to me
a single sentence that was the key to my
realization
there is no virus
infected information doesn't change who
you are
changes what you are
there is a set of circumstances a group
of mental states that when combined
enable a dead soul to etch within your
brain a fatal symbol a black poison that
spreads throughout your mind
it is subtle in the beginning a low
overtone that colors your perception of
how you see the world
making it darker and more meaningless
but slowly the storm begins to take
control of your subconscious
manipulating your conscious into acting
with adrenaline fueled emotional charge
and eventually psychotic delirium
and the fate of the human race shall be
nothing but Fury
as we plunge ourselves into atonement
that we cannot comprehend
it has been observed that infection with
scp-36751 is a rather slow process one
with a dazzling degree of varying
symptoms but all with a single end came
we were wronged
we were terribly wrong
there is no virus
there is an automatic Contagion
only a message ringing throughout
history telling us all to surrender
letting these apparitions play with our
minds and control us like marionette all
we have to do is listen
and we cannot stop listening
listening to the voices
of the words
do you know what I see at the end of
this row
the entire human race every single one a
once good Soul driven into this madness
you horrific identity
satisfy knowing that we too shall burn
it's so selfish
it's all spite and anger
and the thing is that's who we are
deep inside
hell itself hasn't made them any less
flawed than we are
let me realize
we're looking at a reflection of
ourselves
and the figure in the mirror is trying
to pull us in
go to araban Melvis
okay I think that amount does it for
today
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are and you're all dismissed
I would like to give a special thank you
to
big sip
zargaron
oh crop guy
the Morrigan
James Saba
420.
that loser
heroin sick
fire of prime
Indy versus the world
Spencer are doing
rubbish bin 69
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
worthy fire
zazapan
Lam k
segnor
alatreon
your local Foundation agent
derivative
Lost Boy
and Lyndon B Johnson
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you